>> Female Interviewer: Please join me in welcoming
author and journalist Jennifer Egan to Google
Cambridge for today's Authors at Google's
event.
Her most recent novel A Visit from the Goon
Squad is the winner of the 2011 Pulitzer Prize
in fiction.
It also won LA Times Book Prize and the National
Book Critics Circle Award in Fiction.
She is also the author of Emerald City and
Other Stories, The Keep, and Look at Me which
is a nominee, a nominee for the National Book
Award in 2001.
Jennifer, welcome to Google.
>> Jennifer Egan: Thank you for having me.
[applause]
>>Interviewer: So it’s been a year now,
almost a year since you won the Pulitzer Prize.
Can you tell us a little bit more about what
this year has been like for you and sorta
of the afterglow of winning the prize?
>>Jennifer Egan: I think, I mean, I still
am not used to the idea that I won it maybe
I will finally really grab hold of that idea
when someone else wins it.
I’ll say, “No, I won it.”
[laughs]
[laughter]
>>Jennifer Egan: But right now I feel like
it’s still of source of surprise whenever
I think of it which is sort of great you know
this sort of I feel like it has this Groundhog
Day quality to it where every time I have
to, really sort of persuade myself that it’s
real.
I think that in terms of just kind of how
it’s changed the structure of my life it’s
mostly that I’ve had the opportunity to
find a lot of readers for the first time which
is really a thrill.
And, well, it’s you know I could easily
have said, “I’ve done enough for this
book; I’m now gonna move on to my next.”
I made the choice to spend quite a bit of
time really trying to capitalize on the opportunity
to keep finding new readers.
So what that means is that I’ve done a lot
of talking--
[laughter]
>>Jennifer Egan: in the last year and not
a whole lot of writing.
But again that was that was a choice on my
part and I think one reason I made that choice
is that this isn’t my first book.
I know that this kind of thing happens exceedingly
rarely, usually never in a career.
And because my work is often not really perceived
as all of that mainstream, I just don't presume
that I'm gonna have a chance like this again.
In fact, I would say that I presume that I
won't, so I wanna make sure that I really
do everything I can to find as many readers
as I can with this book that surprisingly
and against my own predictions has found such
wide audience and see if I can hold on to
some of them [chuckles] for the next few books,
if I ever write them.
[laughs]
>>Interviewer: That seems like a good strategy
>> Jennifer Egan: [chuckles] We’ll see we’ll
only know a few years from now-
>>Interviewer: [chuckles]
>>Jennifer Egan: if I’m still talking about
Good Squad in five years, we’ll l know the
strategy didn’t pay off-
>>Interviewer: [laughs]
>>Jennifer Egan: quite as I had hoped.
[laughter]
>>Interviewer: But when you were awarded the
Pulitzer, judges called the novel an 'inventive
investigation of growing up and growing old
in the digital age, displaying a big hearted
curiosity about cultural change at warp speed'.
I’m curious how do you think the digital
age is changing us as readers, as writers
what do you make of that sort of literature
in that context?
>>Jennifer Egan: I mean, in terms of how it’s
changing us in a big way it’s such a big
question I don't know if I can answer that
head on.
I know that, I think that the aspect of that
question that I was thinking about consciously
as I worked on Good Squad was the relationship
between the digital and our perception of
time.
And I think one thing that I was thinking
about is the fact that we are much more aware
of the speed at which time passes, because
of technology, I think.
Because of how quickly technology becomes
obsolete.
So for example when I was growing up, by the
time I reached my early twenties, the only
real communications event that had occurred
technologically was the invention of the answering
machine which actually was sort of a big deal
because before that you had no way of knowing
that anyone had actually called you.
[chuckle]
>>Interviewer: [chuckle]
>>Jennifer Egan: And if you got a busy signal
there were, well I guess call waiting would
be the other one.
So if you think about that from zero to twenty
one.
The answering machine and call waiting being
the only two real communications developments
that kind of allowed me to mark change.
And then think about nowadays, a person who
is twenty one and what they’ve witness in
terms of technological evolution.
And the surprising outcome of that it seems
to me is that all of us have a since of being
behind even much younger people who, that
I would expect to feel really on top of things
often express a kind of anxiety about people
who are even younger than they are who’ve
had a slightly different experience that feels
somehow more current because they’ve kind
of come up with whatever technology is predominate
right now.
And which of course will be totally obsolete
in two or three years.
So I think that’s one thing.
I think it, technology allows us all to feel
the passage of time and I think that may have
benefited this book in ways that I never predicted.
Because when I wrote it I really thought it
would be for people over forty.
Because I thought who is gonna care about
a book about time, what young person would
care about that.
And in fact when I was reading Proust in my
early twenties, a book that really fairly
directly inspired this one and which is very,
right on the surface about time, I felt bored
by everything about the book that referenced
time and that seemed to be steeped in nostalgia
and I just thought who cares.
Time meant nothing to me but what I find interestingly
is that even high school students seem sort
of interested in time as a subject now.
Is that technologically motivated?
I don't know.
I mean, I think the big question for me in
all of my books to some degree has always
been how is technology changing and shaping
who we are, internally not just in the obvious
ways that we do things differently but how
does it change who were are to ourselves.
I don’t, I think if I ever really think
I have the answer to that question, I gonna
have to find a whole new direction to go in--
[chuckles]
>>Interviewer: [chuckles]
>>Jennifer Egan: as a fiction writer I don’t
really know but it’s extremely fascinating.
>>Interviewer: Have you ever thought about
writing science fiction?
Just thinking about so many writers in that
genre play with that concept of time
>>Jennifer Egan: I haven’t really
>>Interviewer: Time travel
>>Jennifer Egan: I’m not well read in that
genre at all so I would be very nervous about,
striding in there and thinking I could make
any kind of contribution that wouldn't be
stale and repetitive from the point of view
of someone who is really well read in the
genre.
I, in a very mild way, I bumbled into it in
Goon Squad, purely because I wanted to visit
a character whom we meet in his early twenties
in around 2007, in middle age, so I didn’t
really have a lot of options but to go into
the future and I really didn't want to I kept
thinking there’s gotta be a way around this
maybe I’ll move the whole thing even further
back, so at one point I was sorta moving scenes
from the seventies into the sixties as a way
of avoid going, avoiding going into the twenty
twenties and then I thought, “no, okay I'm
just gonna have to do it,” and I think and
I found it quiet fun to imagine forward I
have to say—
>>Interviewer: [hum]
>>Jennifer Egan: once I had resigned myself
to it.
It didn’t feel like real science fiction
so I think I wasn’t intimidated in a way
that I might have been.
Interestingly, I have sorta, without any real
plans to again ventured more into that realm
with a shorter piece that I’ve written.
That actually is about a character from Goon
Squad although it’s not, it certainly would
never have fit in this book because I think,
structurally, it’s a shift that’s so radical
that it wouldn’t have really worked in amongst
these the chapters in the book but it is,
I would say it could be more overtly called
sci-fi and it seems to have happened without
my really planning it.
>>Interviewer: Do you have a lot of stories
that didn't make it into Goon Squad, like
you talk about it being very structurally,
sorta fit together like a puzzle in a lot
of ways, I found it.
Were there things that you had to say goodbye
to when you were in the editing process.
>>Jennifer Egan: Yes, I mean, there were,
it , as I wrote it, it had very I wrote very
inductively without a clear, it wasn’t that
I had a big clear plan and then I filled in
the pieces.
It was more that I. I was interested in someone
and then I would write about them and then
out of the corner of my eyes, either a time
or a place or a person would catch my eye
and I would think what was that like and how
can I try to explore that more fully and I,
and so I moved through the material that way
really guided by my own curiosity, but there
were areas that I was curious about that I
wasn't able to successfully write about.
I still don't quite know why, it some cases
it was, I had a rule as I worked on the book.
Even though I had such a free flowing approach,
I had decided ahead of time, or once I had
a few chapters, that each chapter would be
about a different person, each chapter would
have a totally different mood and tone and
feel, and each chapter would have to stand
completely on its own.
So when I, each time I was working on something,
I was asking myself, can it meet these three
criteria that was really, that was all I was
asking of each part.
And in the cases of the chapters that didn't
work, they usually failed on all three accounts,
interestingly.
It wasn't like, well this is really amazing
and has a great mood and tone and feel but
it doesn't stand on its own so I won’t use
it, it was more like no strong narrative point
of view, not very compelling or interesting
and only of even the slightest interest because
of what was around it.
So, I think in some cases maybe I had some
wrong ideas about characters and so I sorta
following them into places they didn't want
to go.
There was one chapter I really wanted to write
in the form of epic poetry and I think to
this day if I coulda had that and PowerPoint
in one book—
>>Interviewer: [laughs]
>>Jennifer Egan: it would have been better.
[laughs]
[laughter]
>>Jennifer Egan: But I really cannot write
poetry so, that was a problem.
[laughs]
>>Interviewer: [laughs]
>>Jennifer Egan: And I didn't get far.
[chuckles] And I couldn't do PowerPoint in
the beginning either but that seemed to be
a smaller learning curve.
[laughs]
[laughter]
>>Jennifer Egan: than epic poetry, so.
But I was really inspired by great epic poems
I was reading.
One in particular, Don Juan by Byron is just
a rollicking, great story, I mean Don Juan,
goes, has an affair with Catherine of Russia,
joins a harem briefly because he is hiding
from someone,--
>>Interviewer: [chuckles]
>>Jennifer Egan: and so he is dressed up as
a girl and then, wouldn't you know it, the
sultan picks him to spend the night with.
[laughs]
[Laughter]
>>Jennifer Egan: I mean, there is just such
a great adventure story and but it’s also
very modern.
Byron is sorta giving little asides to the
reader in complaining about his breakfast
that day and I thought, I just want to do
that but, I couldn’t do that.
And then there were others that I struggled
with in one form and ended up using parts
of in other ways.
For example, I tried doing PowerPoint using
a different set of characters originally and
that was unsuccessful, I think, partly because
my first thought was who would use PowerPoint
to tell a story.
And the most obvious answer is a kind of corporate
person; a person who thinks in PowerPoint
a little bit because they use it at work.
But the problem with that was that it actually
heightened instead of reducing the biggest
problem with PowerPoint as a medium for fiction
which is that it feels very corporate.
So, me having a corporate person telling a
story about corporate life, didn't exactly
solve that problem.
[chuckles] So, but then I found that I held
on to the idea of using PowerPoint and found
a different angle of approach.
I had also really been interested in pauses
in songs for a long time, and I hadn’t really
focused a chapter around that but I had kept
trying to slip it in.
I had an academic writing about pauses in
songs in one failed chapter and then I was
finally able to use that in a bigger way in
the PowerPoint.
So I never knew why the ones that didn't work
didn’t work, but I definitely knew they
didn't work.
>>Interviewer: Well, the PowerPoint chapter,
and for those of you who haven't read the
book you have a real treat to look forward
to at the end.
It is it is an entire, rich, surprising chapter
about communication between Sasha, --who is
one of the main characters of the story and
written by her son and her daughter--, and
it’s really clever and surprising.
And I think that, when I came upon that in
the galley that I have here and I didn't know
it was coming.
And I was, turned my book around and like,
what is going to happen [chuckles] and you
really are reading it horizontally.
And it’s, it really shocked me in a way
not, necessarily for what is there but for
the ways in which the characters came through.
Like their voices and that presentation is
just so different.
I thought it was really a good fit for children
of Sasha to be writing it.
Just because her life that you read in the,
that unfolds sort of in the previous eleven
chapters is, it’s really curious and different
and she’s just a very interesting person
so, not to spoil anything for you, but it’s
a great chapter and you did it really well.
>>Jennifer Egan: Thank you
>>Interviewer: One of the things actually
at the very end of the book there is a sentence
in that futuristic, near future chapter where
Scotty takes the stage, and I think it’s
Benny who is really reflecting, this is one
of those moments, that people will say they
were at this concert when he just stood up
and did this thing and he said, at that point
he, everyone wanted to own him and he was
sort of a living myth.
And you write, “doesn't a myth belong to
everyone?”
And at that moment, I just felt like that
line sort of just captured so much what this
book is about and that, time and myth and
through time and memory we acquire our own
myths and we’re writing them all the time
and we are telling our own stories.
And do you think that is anything that technology
can touch, I mean, or is that just as old
as the hills?
>>Jennifer Egan: That’s an interesting question.
I’m, I think probably that’s as old as
the hills and yes, technology can touch it.
I think it’s probably both, I mean, even
that event.
There’s a prior kind of converging event
in the book which is a disaster.
Which is that a publicist has this kind of
ultra-hot party at which every who is anyone
in several countries is included.
And she has this design idea which is that
she hangs these Plexiglas trays with oil and
colored water in them under bright lights
which warm up the concoction and it swirls
around and the lights shine through it and
it looks really amazing.
But what she wasn't thinking about was the
fact that the plastic might melt so she ends
up dumping boiling oil on to all of these
people’s heads and this is really satire.
It’s not an exploration of overcoming trauma—
>>Interviewer: [chuckles]
>>Jennifer Egan: it’s more about sort of,
what it means to be a publicist in some sense,
and questions like that.
Anyways, there’s a point where she later,
having gone to jail and gotten out, reflects
on this event and why it was a failure.
And obviously, in part, is was that she poured
boiling oil on lots of people and ended her
career and caused a lot of them to get little
scars.
But interestingly the scars become such a
mark of honor because it was so hard to be
included at the party that it later turns
out that lots of people have actually burned
themselves with oil--
>>Interviewer: [chuckles]
>>Jennifer Egan: so that it would look later
as though they were at this disastrous party.
Anyways, she takes a moment to also reflect
on the fact that the party itself was totally
wrong.
That it, the timing was wrong, the economy
was about to crash but no one knew it yet.
That as a publicist not just a designer and
understand and someone who understands chemical
properties, and how to.
And she not only failed as an engineer but
she really failed as a publicist to kinda
read the moment.
And she asks the question, “What will be
the next big convergence, what will be the
thing that everyone gathers around?”
And the answer, in the book, and again this
is just meant playfully, I mean it’s fiction
but the answer ends up being a guy who’s
been a quasi derelict whose completely unplugged
in every way and really off the grid because
he is mentally a little bit fragile.
He’s very suspicious of companies knowing
a lot about him, an issue I know we’re all
thinking about a lot lately.
>>Interviewer: [chuckles]
>>Jennifer Egan: And so, but he is, for very
various reasons, sort of hauled in to do this
public performance in Downtown Manhattan by
his friend who’s a successful music producer.
And he is missing a lot of teeth and or a
guess he, his teeth had been repaired by then
but he stands up and he starts playing this
slide guitar and mostly because of technology
because all of the people watching it have
all of their own devices this is now in the
twenty twenties.
And this entire event was really created through
a kind of harnessing of social networking
that I’m imagining a few generations beyond
where we are.
Because of all of the different forces technological
and human and cultural that come to bear on
this moment, for whatever reason he is kind
of raised a loft as a folk hero.
And the idea is that this is kind of a huge
seminal moment in the music industry.
I don't explore what comes after that because
that’s the last chapter.
>>Interviewer: [laughs]
>>Jennifer Egan: But that’s the idea that
there is this question about what the next
moment will be and answer.
And part of the answer is, has a lot to do
with technology.
And I guess, mostly the way technology figures
in that moment, two ways; one is everyone
who is there is there because of technology,
because it’s, an event that’s been powered
by somewhat surreptitious use of social networking
to get people there.
But the other reason is that it presumes a
kind of reaction against connectedness that
makes this man, who is so off the grid and
so unknown, and in a way mysterious, whose
personal information is not anyone’s but
his own.
An object of mystery and excitement.
So I guess those are the two ways that technology
play into that moment.
>>Interviewer : Do you have a favorite story
in the book?
>>Jennifer Egan: Not really, actually.
When it’s, given that I have been talking
about the book now for going on two years.
>>Interviewer: [chuckles]
>>Jennifer Egan: One nice thing about it is
because each chapter has its own kind of own
mood and tone and approach, and in a way my
model there is really a concept album because
the book is so much about the music industry.
And I love the idea of one story that’s
told in so many different ways that part of
the fun of it is the collision of these different
styles against each other in the way that
a concept album is.
But because each chapter has such a different
mood, I feel like it makes it easier for me
not get tired of it, personally.
I can sort of you know if I get tired of reading
one part I can read something totally different;
it doesn't even sound like it’s part of
the same book.
So I don’t really, I have to say that I
don’t.
I have, I would say more that there are a
couple that I never read because I know how
much trouble I had with them—
>>Interviewer: [chuckles]
>>Jennifer Egan: and I feel like they kind
of bear the scars, at least for me, their
very difficult genesis and I’ve sort of
afraid about them.
I’ve never read Out of Body, not once, because
that was probably the hardest one to write.
And it seems like I got away with it from
some people's point of view.
But I know for me, it’s just, it's sort
of a little bit of the problem of the sausage
factory and having sort of seen it made.
And feeling like I don't want to push too
hard against this or it just might all fall
apart.
[laughs]
>>Interviewer: [laughs] Have you found that
readers rally around particular stories of
the book or have had chosen favorites or ones
that maybe even they distance themselves from
more.
>>Jennifer Egan: It seems like readers often
definitely have favorites.
One nice thing is that it doesn't really seem
like consensus on which ones those are which
I’m glad about it.
It makes me feel like there is kind of something
for everyone there.
I have found that men tend to think the main
character is Benny, the music producer, and
women tend to feel that it is Sasha [chuckles]
>>Interviewer: [chuckles]
>>Jennifer Egan: his assistant former assistant.
But, I think that my own feeling is that it
really is both of them.
And so no, it feels like it’s one of those
landscapes that people see very differently
according to who they are.
>>Interviewer : And it’s really interesting,
too, when you think about Benny and Sasha
are the principal charters of the novel but
how their stories unfold.
And the, all the connections that end up happening
between them is one of delightful things about
reading this.
Because especially when I went back to re-read
it I was like, “oh, right, that is how that
person got into their life and that’s another
bridge between the two.”
So the timing of it is so elegant and I feel
like it’s almost like it could be staged.
It’s very purposeful in its timing and it’s
introduction of certain elements.
Was that hard thing to do?
I mean, how did you line up?
It is really choreographed I think, is the
only way to say it.
>>Jennifer Egan: It’s interesting.
I wrote it, you know as I said it, in this
very inductive, almost impulsive kind of curious
way.
And yet, I had a notion that the timeline
would move backwards and that--.
I can't say it guided me but maybe in comforted
me because I thought, “well, I’m writing
it in a very chaotic way but it’s gonna
have a very organized structure once I get
it all done.”
Then I had kind of a shock when I because
I spent a long time just working on the chapters
individually and not working on them together
because I wanted to keep their voices very
distinct from each other.
Then I finally sat down and read it and the
backwards order which was supposed to work
so well.
And I found that it didn't work at all.
It was actually really flat and I thought.
“Okay, so maybe this just isn't gonna work.
Maybe the second part of this book that I
had hoped would happen, which was kinda combustion
of these different parts combined, won't happen
and it will just be some parts.”
But oddly, I actually felt like even the parts
seemed diminished by the whole.
Which is really the opposite of what you are
hoping for when you’re writing a book.
It felt like the whole was less than the sum
of the parts.
And so I thought, why is this happening?
Is it that it’s just not very good or is
there something deeply wrong about the juxtapositions
that I have created here?
And I began to feel that it was the latter
because I felt that like there were all these
opportunities for surprise and kind of pleasure
for the reader that I was thwarting with my
backwards order.
So just to give you one example.
In the second chapter, the record producer
who is going to hear a band that he’s signed
to his label.
He’s thinking about his days as a punk rocker
in the late seventies and it’s two or three
sentences but you think, hopefully, “huh,
he was a punk rocker, interesting.
I wonder what that was like?”
He references a club The Mabuhay Gardens,
which was a very, kind of the epicenter of
the punk moment in San Francisco in the late
seventies.
So hopefully the readers had that fleeting
thought.
In my backwards order, I believe, you wait
eight chapters [chuckles] to arrive at Benny
as a teenager as a punk rocker because we
are waiting for 1979 to come along.
But in fact, the perfect moment for that chapter
to arrive was immediately the next chapter.
To basically let the principle of curiosity
which guided me through the material also
informed the reader's experience.
I think that was what I was kind of missing
that I removed a lot of the fun that I had
had taking these kind of lateral steps for
the reader by imposing this chronology which
is just as limiting when it goes backwards
as it is forward.
So what I realized is that I had to let go
of chronology completely and let curiosity
and little pleasures and satisfactions be
my guide.
And so those little connections that you talk
about and those little surprises were things
that started to matter more when I let them
guide me--
>>Interviewer: [hum]
>>Jennifer Egan: And that was in the end when
I had to but that really fell into place fairly
late that was shortly before I sold the book
and that was a big change that really had
to happen.
>>Interviewer : Well, it’s wonderful it
just really it’s totally what makes it the
page turner it is.
In spite of the fact that the plot, the pace
of it changes as you go from story to story.
But that element is there for every one so
at the end you're just like, 'it’s over
and now there is no more surprises'.
>>Jennifer Egan: You know one thing
>>Interviewer : But you can go back and that’s
the thing it’s like you can go back and
reading it again.
It’s one of those pleasures where you find,
think about characters differently and moments
that I had forgotten about come back to me
and are fresh and so I think that having that
nonlinear sort of approach makes it sort of
unique to read over again.
>>Jennifer Egan: I’m glad to hear that.
I think one thing that I find myself saying
to readers sometimes who are a little bit
confused by the book because it’s not certainly
for a novel very unusually to have no clear
chronology and to have all of these different
voices and moods and textures.
But I think some readers feel a little bit
anxious because they feel like there’s some
bigger picture they should be getting and
might not be getting.
And I try to do everything I can to make people
not feel that way because really the reason
I wrote each chapter to stand on its own was
very specifically that I thought if I’m
asking people to start over thirteen times,
I have to provide a total payoff thirteen
times, it’s not fair any other way.
So if you read the book without making a single
connection between the chapters it should
still be fun.
And the likelihood is that anyone even reading
it in a not very alert way will make some
connections and probably wouldn't see all
of them until a second read of course because
then you know what you are looking for.
And who cares; I’m not demanding that anyone
read it but once--
>>Interviewer: [chuckles]
>>Jennifer Egan: much less twice.
I mean, my goal really was and always is above
all that it just be fun and hopefully feel
kind of fresh.
But I do find myself saying a lot to readers
don't worry and I actually wrote a new introduction
to book groups that I recently posted myself
on Facebook and put it on my website and also
the publisher has it on their readers guide.
Basically just saying this, explaining how
I wrote it and the structure that it has and
absolving people of anxiety and feeling somehow
there are things they need to get and if they’re
not doing that they’re missing something.
Because that’s the last thing I would ever
want anyone to feel.
>>Interviewer : I like that you mentioned
your website because I wanted to call it out
as being particularly good author website
and in my line of work I have seen a lot [laughs]
and some are great and some are really functional.
But this one I thought was very unique because
you have this sort of timeline for the stories
where you select moments in your own life,
places you've been, observations you’ve
had and you use them to introduce each of
the chapters in the book.
And I was curious why you decided to draw
the curtain back like that.
Was it tied to that whole Proustian thing,
the unknown element in the lives of other
people.
>>Jennifer Egan: Well, I think it began a
little less loftily than that.
I knew I wanted a different website.
I felt like the book it had enough technological
savvy about it that the, my old website which
was basically me grinning--
>>Interviewer: [chuckles]
>>Jennifer Egan: and some personal information
seemed insufficient.
And especially I knew, once I was writing
the PowerPoint chapter, I was worried that
my publisher wouldn't publish it.
I thought they’re gonna say you are out
of your mind.
I wrote it after I had sold the book.
They thought I was doing light revisions instead
I was creating a seventy-nine slide PowerPoint
and preparing to wallop them with it.
And I thought what if they say we are not
putting this in and so I thought that’s
fine.
I will just have that chapter heading and
a URL address and it will be on my website.
In fact there is a color version on my website
with a soundtrack that I think is much better.
[laughter]
>>Jennifer Egan: Anyways, I thought so on
the grinning face and personal information
was just not a place where this PowerPoint
could appear.
It didn't work so I thought okay I have to
find a new take on the website.
And I’m not that website oriented I don't
look at a lot of websites.
So I went to a great designer and it’s the
company that’s Another Limited Rebellion
and I said to Noah Scalin, who runs the company,
so I just want you to do something great.
Take a look at the book and just think about
it and just let it rip.
And he said, “well, a okay I have a few
questions for you.”
And he sent me this extremely long questionnaire
with questions like, what do you want people
to feel when they go on the website?
All these things.
And I thought, oh my God, and I called him,
and I said, “no, no, I am paying you to
have the ideas [chuckles]
>>Interviewer: [chuckles]
>>Jennifer Egan: I don't want to fill out
this questionnaire.” and he said, “Then,
well, I’m sorry; we can't work together.”
So I said, “Alright, I’ll fill out the
questionnaire.”
So basically what he ended up saying to me
and what became kind of clear just from filling
out the questionnaire was that I needed to
have the idea.
Because the whole point was that the website
and the book would work together in some way,
That it was not really his vision to have;
it had to be my vision.
So I said, “I don't have any visions about
this; I don't think about websites.” and
he said, “What do you normally do when you
are in this position with fiction?” and
I said, “I go running.”
and he said, “Go running.”
[laughter]
>>Jennifer Egan: So I went running.
And I am not kidding, while running I had
a vision--
>>Interviewer: [chuckles]
>>Jennifer Egan: of how this could work.
It didn't look the way it does because that’s
all him; it’s so beautifully designed.
But I suddenly thought, what if I create a
kind of ghostly echo of the book which follows
various people through various time periods
by using just a little bit of biographical
context for each of those chapters which,
speak about different moments in certainly
New City the life of New York City and also
some degree my life.
I mean I witnessed that punk moment in San
Francisco in the late seventies, etcetera.
It was a strange thing for me to do because
I don't like to write about myself and I don't.
I’ve never blogged I don't tweet I’m pretty
reticent about revealing personal information
not on principle but because I just don't
enjoy doing that kind of writing.
But for this it seemed warranted; it felt
kind of necessary, artistically.
So I went for it and he made it look really
good and so I’m so glad that it worked out.
>>Interviewer : Did you always know that music
was gonna be a central part of the book?
That, could Benny ever be a film producer
or a writer himself--
>>Jennifer Egan: I don't think so, no.
>>Interviewer: Or a music artist?
>>Jennifer Egan: I mean, when I started the
book, I didn't think I was writing a book.
I should have said that.
I thought I was taking a little breather from
a different book that I was trying to avoid
writing by writing a few stories.
Or at first, I thought it was just one story.
I wrote about a women stealing a wallet on
a date and then she briefly mentioned her
ex-boss, a record producer, who she mentions
to her date, sprinkles gold flakes in his
coffee and sprays pesticide in his arm pits.
I thought, “huh, gotta find out why he does
that stuff.”
So I wrote the second, what became the second
chapter about Benny, the other major character.
Just to write that chapter, which I wrote
second without even knowing that I was writing
a book, I had to actually do a fair amount
of research.
Because he’s at work as a music producer
and I didn't even really know the difference
between analog and digital recording.
So I had to spend a fair amount of time on
the phone with a mixer, talking about that
technology.
And in the course of that, what I think maybe
the reason that I really locked in with the
industry, was that it was poignant to talk
to this guy who had worked in music industry
for years and constantly have this sense with
him of a before and after in the industry.
When the before being when it was strong and
the after being the current free fall which
still has not really ended, of the industry
trying to find a workable business model in
a digital age.
So I guess that got me interested in what
it felt like from the inside.
There were also a lot of other reasons that
I had wanted to write about the music industry
for long time as a journalist.
Never could really get an assignment which
was really annoying.
But part of the reason that I couldn't get
an assignment was that I knew nothing about
the industry and had no connections.
The reason I wanted the assignment was so
that I could learn about the industry and
get connections [chuckles]
>>Interviewer: [chuckles]
>>Jennifer Egan: but the New York Times Magazine
was looking for some kind of some opening
move from me and I was looking for one from
them.
So that never really happened.
So there was kind of a long standing interest
in the industry.
And I think also, as I said, Proust was so
important as an inspiration.
And music plays a huge role in search of lost
time both as a plot element and also as an
organizing principle.
I mean, the novel is really constructed very
symphonically.
So I guess in a way, that may have, obviously
it is a different type of music, but I think
it may have suggested to me a kind of musical
model.
And I think, as we all know from our own lives,
time and music are very deeply linked.
I mean, music is a kind of time machine and
I’ve become only more aware of that as I
put meaningful songs from my past on my iPod
and find myself immediately having memories
linked to those songs every time I listen
to them.
So, and actually one final reason, there’s
so many reasons.
I think one reason I loved the idea of the
book as a concept album is that the atomized
way that we buy music now has in some ways
endangered the concept album.
The big musical vision that you--.
OK, you have the two hits or one hit and that
makes everyone buy the album.
But the great songs are never those hits.
They're always the little in-between ones
that are odd and become beloved through lots
of listening.
But now we just buy the hits or the ones that
we heard on the radio or that SoundHound captured.
And so I guess I felt nostalgic for that form,
for the big musical vision that with all of
its component parts and the kind of majesty
of all of them colliding and having a listener
engaged in all of that.
>>Interviewer : What were you listening to
when you were writing, do you remember or
were you consciously not listening?
>>Jennifer Egan: Oh no, I normally don't listen
to music when I work.
When I wrote this book, I listened a lot.
One reason was that it was hard for me; the
biggest technical challenge for me was to
recalibrate so radically from one chapter
to the next.
Because, since they don't feel like they're
one book, it was just a lot of changing of
my own mindset and shedding of one voice to
try something totally different for the next
chapter.
And I found that music really helped me do
that.
Sometimes it was just locating me in time.
So not surprisingly, writing about the punk
rock scene in San Francisco in the late seventies,
I was listening to music from the punk rock
scene--
>>Interviewer: [chuckles]
>>Jennifer Egan: from the late seventies.
Which in a way was so fascinating because
bands that never even recorded are still on
YouTube.
And it was really moving, actually, to watch
them.
Many of them were dead by then, by the time
I was watching these videos.
Anyways, so yes, I listened a lot and I think
it helped to sink me into the mood and the
tone of each chapter.
Sometimes, interestingly, the music that helped
me was not music that you would think would
be connected to a particular chapter.
So unlike the punk rock getting me into the
mood to write about punk rock, when I was
writing the PowerPoint chapter which is called
Great Rock and Roll Pauses.
And it’s about a kid with an Asperger’s
obsession with the pauses in rock and roll
songs and he times them and measures them
and loops them so he’s just listening to
the pauses continuously.
And of course I listen to songs with pauses
as I worked on that chapter.
But when I got very stuck, for some reason,
there was a song by the band Lets Go Sailing
called Sideways and whenever I would listen
to that song, I felt like it captured the
mood that I wanted in that chapter.
There’s something young, very young and
kind of hopeful about the voice and so at
one point when I really thought I might not
be able to finish the chapter I put Sideways
on repeat and walked around Brooklyn and I
listened to it continuously for hours.
>>Interviewer: [chuckles]
>>Jennifer Egan: I’m sorry to say I basically
can't listen to that song anymore [laughs]
>>Interviewer: [laughs]
>>Jennifer Egan: I pretty much exhausted it
in that one shot but it helped me finish the
chapter.
I really feel that it did.
>>Interviewer: Interesting.
So you’ve said that the you think of the
novel as a really elastic form that, in fact,
can be conceived as really form-bending by
use of language and style.
Do you think that other sort of integers like
format or display or the ways in which people
interact with novels can be as form-bending
as like pieces of a novel itself?
>>Jennifer Egan: I’m not sure I understand
your question
>>Interviewer: Like what if the, I’m thinking
about, if we use language and style to push
the limits of what a novel is.
Can we redefine what those sort of limits
are by the ways in which we consume them or
find them or share them?
Or do you think that there is that that malleability
of form extends to like what the reading is
like.
>>Jennifer Egan: Theoretically, yes but I’m
not totally it’s so hypothetical—
>>Interviewer: Right
>>Jennifer Egan: that I’m not sure what
to envision there.
But I guess the big thing I would say what
has always driven me to do work that I guess
you could call experimental, although I never
think of it that way, is usually just that
the people that I’m writing about and kind
of what needs to happen.
That’s always what gets me there.
For example, I was very interested in writing
in PowerPoint but I could only really get
any kind of traction in the form when I found
a story that could actually only be told in
PowerPoint.
So and the reason that I say that, that might
sound odd, but the story that I tell in PowerPoint
is a very sweet actually I would even say
sentimental simple story very little happens.
It’s about a family that loves each and
struggles and I mean just saying that you
think “ahh, cliché alert” but the thing
is that interestingly the coldness the very
corporate feeling that makes PowerPoint so
difficult as a medium for fiction, I think
actually worked in that case, for those who
agree that it works, because it off set the
sweetness and somehow balanced it in some
way.
So I’m willing to try anything and open
to reading anything that is going to give
me a great story about people and what they
do.
And if it’s done in a way that is interesting
and innovative, I feel like that’s all the
more exciting.
What I, personally, am wary of, certainly,
as a writer is the impulse to do wacky things
with form and kind of impose them onto work
that is basically, probably, would best be
told conventionally.
It's a great effort but it often doesn't end
up really working.
What I think, what I’m most interested in
about experimentation, so called experimentation,
is that it lets me tell stories that I couldn't
tell otherwise.
That’s what’s so fun about it.
In the case of the PowerPoint, I, ironically
it’s a story I couldn't tell otherwise because
it would be so clichéd and slow and simple
and way too familiar.
But in a way, all of Goon Squad is this very
kind of laterally moving story about a lot
of different people whose lives who overlap
and somewhat entangle.
And I don't know how I could really deliver
that story in a more conventional novel form.
I think that the centrally, the central nature
of the novel composition and the relative,
compared to Goon Squad, uniformity of tone
and voice would have sunk my effort to try
to do what I was trying to do here.
So that’s really why I had to do what I
did it was just serving that particular story
and I’m open to anything that is serving
a particular story.
Whatever, however, the wackier the better
why not.
[chuckles] I guess one other thing I would
say about that is there is a lot of fear out
there right now about the future of the novel
and people are often saying why will people
read if there are so many distractions.
And I really share that anxiety.
I feel it most as a parent because I have
two boys who absolutely would love to play
video games from morning until night if I
let them and they would pick those over reading
any day of the week.
And that, I think, it’s not a good thing
and on a personal level it literally fills
me with terror.
So I feel those anxieties but I really do
sort of as a writer I feel like if we do our
job, the novel should remain very strong.
It should not be sapped and weakened by these
by whatever new technology comes along.
It should be strengthened.
It should suck all of it into itself and use
it and I feel like people are not gonna read
because everyone tells them it’s like taking
vitamins and it will make you smarter.
That is just a chore and a job.
No one’s gonna read if that’s the reason.
They’re gonna read--.
It’s our job to write stuff that is irresistible
that you can't put down, that feels exciting
and important.
And I really, maybe this is just ridiculous
optimism, maybe this is just what I have to
tell myself to get through the day, but I
do believe that if we do that the novel will
thrive will continue to thrive.
>>Interviewer: I have just one more question
for you before we take questions from the
audience and it was, how you feel about writing
now after having won the Pulitzer, all these
prizes.
Like I would imagine that level of success
and attention would be overwhelming but also
maybe liberating because you’re like, wow,
I won the Pulitzer.
Like, just, I could just write whatever I
want now [chuckles] but maybe it’s not that
easy.
I don't mean to simplify it but like, it does
does it open you up to say what is after this.
>>Jennifer Egan: I look forward to really
knowing the answer to that question
>>Interviewer: [laughs]
>>Jennifer Egan: I have found the sort of
strange novella story that I’ve written
about the character from Goon Squad.
I felt completely, I felt like it had no--.
The Pulitzer or anything that happened with
Goon Squad seemed to have no impact on that.
It’s just the project was it had a kind
of center of gravity of its own and it just
kind of pulled me through it.
I’m hoping that’s how it will be with
my next book too.
The fear is that I’ll feel tremendous crushing
pressure and be convinced that this is no
good and that everyone will hate it but, in
a way, I also feel like, in a way, I know
that it's whatever I do next probably forever
won't get the kind of love that Goon Squad
has gotten.
So I accept that right on the outset.
I’m grateful for what I’ve had and my
personal goal is just to keep getting better.
I mean, I really wanna top Goon Squad and
try to do something that’s different and
very strong, stronger, ideally in its own
way.
That’s really the bar that I’ve set.
So I’m not, I feel like I’m not that worried
about what the world says because I kind of
already know what it will say and it’s it
inevitably will seem to be less good than
a book that’s gotten all this love showered
on it.
And that’s fine.
But I do hope that I can do something that
I think is interesting and strong and I guess
that’s really no different from the way
I’ve felt every time so I don't know that
it’s really changed the feeling—
>>Interviewer: uh huh
>>Jennifer Egan: deeply.
>>Interviewer: Do you look back at your earlier
books and think that you topped yourself with
this book?
I mean, I love The Keep and that was a totally
different book; haunting and wonderful.
And I can't compare them because I think they're
so different.
But I wonder if you think about them that
way, like, if one sort, of that you, just
raising the bar each time.
>>Jennifer Egan: My personal favorite is Look
at Me so one before The Keep.
So I guess, I feel as you do that they're
so different it’s a little bit hard to really
compare them.
I think that it may be that Goon Squad does
its job better than Look At Me but I guess,
I still feel, that maybe Look at Me is more
ambitious in a certain way.
So it certainly was full of a lot of very
big abstract questions.
I feel like I just like got out there—
>>Interviewer: [chuckles]
>>Jennifer Egan: and I thought “how has
mass media image culture impacted inner life?”
I mean, that’s a pretty big question.
[chuckles] That’s what I was trying to answer.
Or although, interestingly, I think the answer
was different than what I thought it would
be.
I think began the book feeling pessimistic
and emerged from it feeling optimistic.
But yeah, so I guess I feel that each one
has managed to do something different from
the others and I'm pleased about that and
that’s kind of all I know and I just wanna
try and keep doing that.